hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
kind of book entertainment I am your
host Walter Bernays yak and this is it
folks you guys been asking about this
video for a long time so we're gonna
give it to you
this is Young Justice ladies and
gentlemen you guys excited for this yeah
I am excited all right before we get
into that this is a big announcement
next week Killing Joke finally we'll be
reviewing Killing Joke so excited to see
that let me see in theaters and come on
the show and review for you guys the
hype so exciting was it a fending off
fathom events at 300 more theaters yeah
the showing it's the biggest biggest
like found event forever yeah I can't
wait only to me to also as always want
to remind you guys to like the new
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
awesome comics show every Thursday we
are going to be putting up a brand new
video exclusively to that Facebook page
last week Porter and I shared our
thoughts on the Batman V Superman dawn
of Justice Ultimate Edition and what we
thought about that so go ahead and check
that out if you haven't there's a lot
more exclusive videos on there so go
ahead and like that Facebook page now
let's get down to the intros you guys
know who these people are I think except
for every comment that says who I need
you only been here for you know 17 years
now but which one of us among us really
truly knows who we are about you know no
baby I didn't up into those comments
right keep commenting who we are you and
then I look inward I don't find myself I
know what's going on man what a find a
wait that's me
nice glasses thank you cool stuff that's
a good shirt Sarah which I I like Sarah
because I'm a fan of Translator tops but
a lot of people don't like her well yeah
I mean she's not Patriot Petrie's
awesome but finally freaking Petrie
shirts I know where that do it over here
mr. Brian Porter the irish-american
himself I see Irish and the Americans
shirt that's great yeah Batman it's a
good sure I had that true - yeah we're
twins barely you know we look just alike
absolutely tell us apart or not all
right guys I want to get into young
just okay so we're gonna do our usual
thing this is a spoiler warning if you
haven't seen young justice for whatever
reason go watch it and watch all of it
season really good yeah go ahead and
watch it right now positives what were
some of your favorite who were some of
your favorite characters we'll go with
Anna first shocker I loved Magan I
really loved her they do a lot of really
cool character exploration especially
with her powers the fact that she's like
so powerful but like it's scary yeah a
few times it gets a little a little
scary how she basically puts people into
comatose states because she's so
powerful but she starts out so like I
guess not even innocent and just really
like go-get-'em attitude and I really
like that she's she's more than that she
really has like a really great depth of
character and then I also love love
Aqualad he's such a cool character
especially the second season yeah I like
him in the second season a lot um but
even just his like weapons that he has
there they look like electric eels and
stuff yeah and then he can make them
into shields he can make him into swords
make him into whips you know I really
love his character as well he's got some
cool stuff going on too
so I'd say they're my two favorites okay
I agree with that Porter it's really
hard to pick because like a lot of the
kick all the characters had awesome
elements to them and I really liked them
all for various reasons wall-e is
probably one of my favorites I freaking
love wall-e
and it upset me that he wasn't in season
two our episode yeah season two is as
much but Wally was just phenomenal he
was super funny I loved him I loved I
loved dick he he was funny and he was an
interesting take on like you know Dick
Grayson Robin you know and I really
liked him I liked his overlapping
whelmed underwhelmed overwhelmed his
language thing there I thought that was
really funny I'm like that he grows as a
character in it too you don't see him
like sure of himself right away yeah
yeah it's kind of like you know taking
the lead from Aqualad you want me to
lead like that was was really good I
like that and how they kind of
translated into
and season 2 was the same thing I really
like that and then you know seeing him
as night Nightwing in the season 2 was
really cool I came and I really liked I
also liked Aqualad a lot - I thought he
was great yeah impulse mm-hmm art was
cool
he's freaking so funny yeah I loved him
and then I also loved Superboy a lot too
I thought he had a really good character
arc a lot of depth and showed from
season 1 to season 2 ways yeah his you
know growth and maturity in season one I
didn't really I was he was brash and he
you know he's dealing with a lot of
stuff and I thought that was really good
he's kind of a whiny baby baby he was
forced into existence I know I know but
it was it got a little much for me for
him first season but second season I
really like super angry his growth was
really cool
yeah my favorites Nightwing in the
second season and you know has Robin in
the first season Dick Grayson I love
Dick Grayson general and this may be
like the best on-screen portrayal of him
I think yeah you think about it I mean
Batman and made series he's great in but
he's not as much of the focus as he
isn't here I think it's I think it's
probably pretty safe to say this is like
the best on-screen portrayal of
Nightwing slash Robin slash decreasing
probably that's out there and I love
Wally West man what what is my flash
he's my flash I'm Barry Allen it's Wally
West that's how it's all about yeah yeah
I loved Wally West and this to it like
his trademark like humor and how quick
he was like witted and quick in real
life yeah he's great just his it's a
lark - and then him kind of getting out
of the superhero business in season 2
which I was with you with like why
wasn't he in more of it but I wanted to
see more Wally but didn't really go into
too much of a why just yeah yeah I just
want to get out it seemed like there had
to be some kind of inciting incident for
that that we didn't see that yeah but
I've gotten into it in season 3
right
also dr. fate is a badass yeah I want to
ask this anyone out there what are some
good doctor fate like trades can you
guys comment some because I want to read
up more on doctor fate I've liked doctor
fate for a long time he was freaking
cool zone this so give me some
suggestions on some doctor fate book so
I can read but he was cool I mean like I
loved that he's basically can upgrade
for everybody it's like so we put sound
on Aqualad and I'm Zatanna and stuff it
was all great yeah he's like no he's not
gonna be he just takes notes like what
okay not a main character but G Gordon
Godfrey yeah because I wanted you to
experience I loved getting to hear you
guys like experienced in it for the
first time that was really cool I really
like sphere post Superboy just picks up
like no pets yeah wolf is cool too
mm-hmm angry
alright well we talk about our favorite
characters how about some favorite
episodes any any ones that stick out to
you there's a lot like I like season one
a little bit better than season 2 there
is yeah it's for me there was just there
were episodes in season one that just
really just stuck with me a lot more and
it was like oh wow
failsafe fail-safe episode 16 would be
annually invasion it was the you know
unwinnable scenario and how that
happened that was really and like
changes at all like that was crazy it
was it was really it was a big episode
and just seeing all these heroes die
like I was nuts yeah this is a really
good misplaced episode 19 with the
missing kids and adults and you know
Billy Batson and you know captain
I love Captain Marvel in this do not
like it do you didn't love him in this I
thought he was a little child child it's
not I know but I'm trying to yeah he's
not always portrayed that way but there
were times when it was a little on the
nose for me but I didn't I didn't hate
him there were times when really I
wanted more I definitely did not want my
warner couple episodes just to focus on
Billy
he should have been like kind of because
eventually they found out that he was a
kid they'd have been a thing where he
kind of like it's introduced to the team
too as well as being in the Justice
League he should have been able to
bounce in Justice League where he's like
sitting there and they're like well he
shouldn't be allowed on he's a kid dr.
fate yeah I love that I love that he's a
kid in in a big in a adults body I think
that's a great premise I just I love
Captain Marvel and this was it was
really that episode misplace was really
cool how easy will the pocket line
between like I thought it was just a
really enjoyable it stuff like
cold-hearted was definitely one of my
favorite that was a lot of heart and
like oh just how he fell to the end like
just you know 12 seconds oh his heart
breaking it was her it was so it's such
a good character episode for Wally's
awesome
really good my I would say my favorite
episode is definitely image I think it's
episode 21 in season 1 and I love the
mesh Miss Martian storyline in general I
think they do some really really cool
stuff with her character and I like that
in general the team kind of everyone has
these secrets and these insecurities and
these things that they're trying to work
through and that's part of them being
young and part of them trying to find
their identity as superheroes and some
of them are like just getting into it or
just coming to this earth or being born
ish so you know released into the world
you know and I think that one's a really
really good episode to really show
McGann's like really like most sincere
like insecurities of
herself and to the point where she you
know brain blast team members yeah I
love that episode and what they do with
her in that I'd say that's my favorite
okay my favorite top one was depths the
season 2 episode where Artemis dies yeah
I love ornaments by the way I like that
boy factor a lot she's got that like
scratchy lower voice I really like her a
lot mm-hmm
yeah so in this I mean we find out that
cows there's also a double agent in this
episode oh it's the line when Nightwing
holds up that picture they took in the
first season yeah I was like oh and it
was right before you find out that she's
alive so I was like oh she's like it was
a rollercoaster ride of emotions in
episode so that's my favorite episode
loved it also agendas the first season
episode where we find out Superboy's
origins that's when I was finally on
board super because before that I didn't
generalized always frickin annoying but
but from then on I I was pretty much on
Team Superboy yeah I loved that and then
we got to see bizarro
I mean he's looking in the mirror and he
does the s honest yeah and so I was like
it has to be bizarre but it's not my
guess it kind of is it has to be bizarre
I mean he drew the backward I know he
drew over there he never shows up again
and he doesn't have but he like bizarro
has opposite powers
yeah whatever again it's kind of as our
yeah bizarre representation I think
there's a better a better
bizarro than Supergirl yeah then in
Supergirl season one oh yeah that's like
we're not here
the season 2 episode bloodlines that's
Bart as impulse comes back and he meets
Barry is his grandson and Wally is yeah
we saw four speedsters it was so big
Eric's in the show too before the dawn
was a season 2 episode where he first
meet the black beetle or is the first
big fight yeah Magan also attacks
Calders mind and basically leaves him
that can have a nice day that was a
great has to like go through everything
there where she's like no I'm right I'm
right this is I should be able to do
whatever I need you to like get here and
then that's the one where she's like I
was like she thought she was right
because they were so wrong and then we
found out when I saw Cal there's blank
stare I was just like yeah this is just
like I said this definitely has a lot of
ups and downs and a lot of big twists
that you don't see color show even from
episode episode sometimes it's kind of
like oh you know I'm just going to
episodes like what yeah this and this
and this and I was like oh oh this makes
it even better it's great and I'm like I
said cold hard news also
yeah right after with it okay so we're
talking about favorite characters
favorite episodes that's most of the
positives about this negatives do we
have any Porter yes the five-year jump I
do not like time jumps from season to
season or anything like that or even in
movies I don't like them I think they're
lazy writing especially in TV shows it's
like okay we have these characters we
want to get to get them to a certain
point but there's gonna be a lot in
between let's just time jump and then
all of these big things that has now
changed Oh we'll just do some throwaway
lines and a couple of like one-minute
explanations and then you're moving
forward and it's like there was so much
interaction with these characters that I
think we missed that would have been
better than season two like I like Toula
dying like how did tula die and you know
with Aqualad and how he dealt with that
and then what I mean they said how a
Megan McGann was kind of like like
mentally like messing with people on how
she kind of controlled
Conner's feeling is innocent that's why
he broke up with her but I would have
loved to have seen all that you know I
want to see why Wally and Artemis get
out of the game
yeah no I want to see I liked the time
jump personally but I like that as a way
to tell a story because we're all of a
sudden in this new world and you're like
wheat what happened and then they slowly
like slip things and you're like oh my
god that happened while this was missing
so I actually have opposite view i I
liked the time jump because of the ways
they were able to like throw in new
twists where you're like oh
Cheshire was pregnant and the baby was
that was like a bender yeah it was it
worked I don't think it didn't work I
think it worked but it's just there's so
much in there that I would have much
rather seen what we did see you know
what I mean so I mean for this at work
other stuff it doesn't this work that it
worked in most part and they answered
the questions pretty succinctly yeah
yeah but yeah I just I didn't feel like
my hand was being held like story-wise
in the shoe in general for a children's
show and I know that's one of the
reasons it was canceled because as an
animated show they wanted more boys to
buy stuff so I did hear cancelled
because of yeah well we'll get into that
in a while but just gonna see the over
here chili to salute kill you I don't
think that time jumps through you're
right don't always work and I don't
think if they would have kept going with
if there's like a handful of seasons of
Young Justice I don't think they should
have had a big time jump every season
right but for once or maybe if they did
one more time in another season but but
this I thought it worked I mean they
only used like I said we didn't get any
more episodes unfortunately but but for
just from one to two I thought I was
really cool that we you know we see Dick
Grayson as Robin we see him as Nightwing
and he's leading the team calories
everybody what the hell was yeah I like
figuring it out right you know like why
did this happen
plus we get like the introduction to the
new younger people which is really cool
with Beast Boy with back I want to see
well
I mean we can infer be crying the blood
I was fine with just the one line with
like sister I was like sister I'm like
oh yeah the blood oh that's so cool I
like just figuring out those those kind
of line mm-hmm I thought it they carry a
lot of weight so yeah I like the time
jump anything negative
besides the toys any negatives I mean
that it took me a little while to get
into everyone's like this is amazing the
first like five episodes or so I was
like this ain't that good three episodes
in like no I can't so I knew you'd love
season to you yes season two yeah I mean
not so much better than season one but I
thought it improved on everything I
think maybe my one negative is like
maybe during season one and it's
possible it's my fault but the whole
like secret agent thing I wasn't really
following like that there was like a
double agent throughout it like they
would mention it you're in they're like
oh yeah I forget that keeps being like I
didn't wear is like season two the fact
that like held her was like undercover
that was like a whole thing that I liked
maybe and maybe I'm nitpicking but like
the whole like that there's a spy you
know okay one thing that's one thing I
didn't like with season two like and
they had all these new kids like they
didn't really explain too many of them
like the beetle got some now I was yeah
yeah Guardian and then he's like a
couple other people and I was like I
went to school with those guys then he
just becomes they're like missions
missions not leader but he Gordon a
mission coordinator or something a
dispatched I get now what I was like why
like why yeah where did that come from
that was one one the only thing they
just didn't explain the character is
that much like okay Wonder Girl or
whatever her name was like okay cool but
like why whatever what you know he's my
girl yeah I've never heard of Wonder
Girl honestly I did not know there was a
Wonder Girl and then she pops up I'm
like who's she one reach into the comics
I'm fine I'm Nagar
I'm sorry I'm talking like that even I
Ana's like freaked out talking like I'm
Carly that's like Tim Curry trying to do
that
that's what is so much deeper in this
though it's like even it's like Tim Tory
exponentially raised to Tim Karina's
like it seriously this entire pile is
just like the entire time I think I know
it is ok I like kind of how we get news
updates from am telling way of being
like so we should support the reach and
every time he says something you would
not like he always rolled his are on the
reached oh that's great ok we gotta
hurry this up where does this show rank
for you guys in terms of DC animated
shows like Batman Emmett series and
Justice League where does this rank is
this number one is number one but it's
up there
yeah it's in my top 5 I will go with
number 4 for yes series number one and
then Batman Beyond Justice League and
then this not just League Unlimited just
right Justice League I consider that the
same show honestly but I you know I
unlimited was like a little different
email you know this justice leaves a
little bit of a different format
if you ever review on the show it's
gonna be the same we're gonna review it
as Justice League justice the same
company it's number four okay I know you
think okay I definitely say Batman
animated series number one yeah it's
pretty much untouchable okay Justice
League honestly I don't know if this I'm
I'm the whole is better than Justice
League you're not it's it's close
honestly no it's great mmm-hmm so I
don't have to go back into Justice
League and but we also yes Justice
League in this channel we get done and
then Bruce Greenwood as Batman yes from
I freaking love in the animation I
really love in this I feel like it's on
par with avatar last airbender and I
don't love the character miles in this
but I like Iowa yeah they were my do I
was not like I didn't I have a problem
with the money well I was worried
Bruce Timm I was like no this totally
fit like this totally fit I felt very
great like they're all different and
they're all like they're there yeah you
know but not all of them have the same
like torso and tiny baby right yeah with
them and beyond stuff I'd say in general
this is better than Batman out and
beyond just for me maybe not better than
return the joke of the movie but but in
the series it's probably better just in
my opinion but it's it's up there I
would say top three two as well okay we
gotta hurry up to this but Cartoon
Network canceled this after season two
of course and now the possibility of
season three has been on Netflix it's
gonna air exclusive deny flicks it's
possible it's gonna happen right yeah I
don't remember what the exact one was
but there was a lot of fans out there
caldor's what sector was doing it yeah
Phil Lamarr I think his name is but yeah
they were there was a lot of them trying
to push it on Twitter being like hey
like you know I would love this way to
do that if you wanna if you want it to
come back go by the blu-rays or go binge
it on Netflix like follows that and
that's how I watch it I just watch it on
Netflix yeah we all we all know most
most Network Netflix original stuff is
really good I can think of like examples
but for the most part like a lot of the
Netflix original series are really well
done so if Netflix is the one that's
gonna take it over yeah but the only
thing with it is they need to pick up
exactly where they left off okay really
quickly pic of the week so none of us
really have a lot of Teen Titans type
books so I picked Val for the cow this
is a big night link story
this is him taking over for Batman so
this is a big culmination of his arc
this was mm like 11 or something Tony
Daniel was the writer I got him to sign
actually pretty cool
so yeah it's only dinner wrote this Tim
Drake is also in this book Jason Todd
everyone's trying to be the new Batman
since Bruce Wayne has died in this
story right before this black Canary's
also in this there's a lot of characters
from young just to show that are also in
this and it's just really cool to see
Nightwing sort of take on that
leadership role like he did in Young
Justice took over the team he takes over
the Batman family basically in this so
it's pretty cool okay social media for
every body
Ayana where can we find you on the
social medias Twitter Facebook here yeah
they're everywhere facebook.com slash
awesome border awesome Porter truly
awesome you can find me on Twitter at
awesome underscore Walter and as always
like the Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome comic show go back and
like we're talking about the ultimate
edition BBS importer took a look at that
exclusive to the Facebook page every
Thursday new videos on the Facebook page
also with the Facebook page like I know
that there is a lot of content a lot
that you guys like about Young Justice
so if we didn't cover something that you
wanted to talk about just post on our
Facebook page and we can talk to you we
yeah we try and talk to everybody
everyone more messages so just you know
throw something on our wall and let's
get some conversations going because I
would love to talk about this more okay
all right so next week like I said
Killing Joke everybody I'm sorry the
joke will be killed next week so get
excited along with others yeah so for
everyone here I'm telling that's I'm G
Gordon Godfrey and we see you on the
next page the reach